Il y a trois théorèmes dévastateurs des
mathématiques de la démocratie.
Ces trois théorèmes semblent prouver qu’il
y a quelque chose de fondamentalement erroné
dans le concept même de démocratie.
Le premier théorème est le théorème d’Arrow.
Ce théorème affirme la seule façon de combiner
les préférences d’individu en une préférence
de groupe en garantissant les principes d’unanimité
et d’indépendance vis-à-vis des alternatives
non-pertinentes est la dictature.
Le second théorème est le théorème de
Gibbard-Satterthwaite.
Il affirme que le seul scrutin unanime et
sans dilemme du “vote utile” est la dictature.
Le troisième théorème est un théorème
de Gibbard.
Il rajoute que si l’on autorise les scrutins
aléatoires, alors le seul scrutin unanime,
anonyme et sans dilemme du “vote utile”
est la dictature aléatoire.
Et avant que vous ne trouviez ce que je dis
scandaleux, je vous rappelle qu’il s’agit
là de théorèmes mathématiques, et qu’aucune
position idéologique ne peut remettre en
question la validité de ces théorèmes.
Autre chose, ça ne veut pas dire non plus
qu’il n’est pas possible de créer un
système démocratique.
Après tout, en France ou aux États-Unis,
nous vivons dans des systèmes démocratiques.
Cependant, comme on l’a vu dans les épisodes
précédents, ces systèmes démocratiques
sont arbitraires, imparfaits et, je dirais
même dangereux pour l’avenir de nos sociétés,
parce qu’ils poussent entre autres à la
bipolarisation.
Et bien, ce que disent les trois théorèmes
antidémocratiques, c’est qu’il n’y
a pas de solution parfaite.
Tout système démocratique va être inéluctablement
victime de faiblesses.
Alors, je vous vois venir, vous allez vouloir
me parler du vote à la proportionnelle.
Il faut bien voir qu’il s’agit en fait
là d’une façon de procrastiner les décisions
politiques et à les déléguer aux politiciens.
Ces politiciens vont ensuite devoir établir
des coalitions, faire des magouilles et accepter
des concessions pour déterminer une ligne
politique directrice.
Je ne dis pas que la proportionnelle, c’est
mal.
Je dis juste que ça ne résout pas vraiment
le problème de l’élection d’un président
par le peuple, ou, plus généralement, le
choix d’une alternative parmi un ensemble
prédéterminé en fonction des préférences
de l’électorat.
Bref.
Assez divaguer.
Revenons-en à nos trois problèmes d’impossibilité.
Commençons par le théorème d’Arrow, qui
permettra à Kenneth Arrow de gagner le prix
Nobel d’économie en 1972.
Ce théorème dit qu’il est impossible de
bien définir des préférences d’un groupe.
Ce théorème est le moins important des trois,
surtout pour la démocratie, où on n’a
pas besoin de décrire les préférences du
“peuple” vis-à-vis de tous les candidats
à la présidentielle.
A priori, on se moque pas mal de savoir si
le peuple préfère le Nouveau Parti Anticapitaliste
à la Lutte Ouvrière.
En politique, oui.
Mais ce n'est pas le cas dans d'autres votes,
comme l'élection du Ballon d'or, celui de
la personnalité préférée des français
ou encore de qui recevra des financements
pour la recherche.
Dans ces contextes, il est important d'agréger
les préférences des électeurs en une préférence
de groupe, car, pour les candidats, être
le 21eme préféré du groupe peut avoir des
conséquences très différentes par rapport
à être le 246eme.
Mais alors, on pourrait exiger que cette agrégation
se fasse de manière juste.
Par exemple, on aimerait que si tout le monde
préfère Griezmann à Ribéry, alors le classement
de Griezmann soit alors meilleur que celui
de Ribéry.
C'est ce que l'on appelle le critère d'unanimité.
Mais on aimerait aussi que le classement relatif
entre Griezmann et Ribéry ne dépende pas
de la présence ou de l'absence de Benzema
dans la liste des candidatsau ballon d'or.
C'est ce que l'on appelle l'indépendance
des alternatives non-pertinentes, dont on
a vu dans l'épisode précédent qu'il pouvait
causer l'émergence d'un bipolarisme exacerbé.
Et bien, le théorème d’Arrow affirme malheureusement
que ces deux propriétés très désirables
sont incompatibles, à moins de considérer
que les préférences du groupe seront entièrement
déterminées par les préférences d’un
seul électeur.
Et pour ceux qui meurent d’envie de comprendre
les causes de ce théorème, je vais en parler
dans l’épisode Hardcore de jeudi.
Avançons.
Passons au théorème de Gibbard-Satterthwaite.
Pour moi, ce
théorème est un vrai problème pour la démocratie.
Il dit qu’il faut choisir entre : ne pas
demander l’avis du peuple, ne proposer au
peuple que des référendums, et mettre chaque
électeur dans un dilemme du vote utile.
Et pour moi, ça fait mal, parce que le dilemme
du vote utile est un énorme problème.
On l’a vu dans l’épisode précédent,
il pousse les politiciens à s’organiser
pour réduire notre capacité à nous exprimer
et nous renferme ainsi dans des cases prédéfinies.
Pire encore, si le peuple a voté de façon
“utile” et non pas selon ses vraies préférences,
l’élection du président reste-t-elle alors
utile ? Comme aiment l’affirmer les candidats
élus, « le peuple a parlé ». Certes, mais
s’il a voté de façon “utile”, c’est
qu’il n’a pas dit ce qu’il pensait.
Le peuple a parlé, mais il a menti.
C’est aussi ainsi que nombre de débats
politiques se posent la question : quel est
le moins pire des candidats ? Trop souvent,
on en vient à voter contre un candidat, plutôt
qu’à exprimer nos vraies préférences.
Laisser la porte ouverte au dilemme du vote
“utile”, c’est limiter la liberté d’expression
de l’électorat, et dévier une bonne partie
du débat politique sur les stratégies de
vote plutôt que vers les vraies questions
de vision politique qu’il faudrait adresser.
Malheureusement, le théorème de Gibbard-Satterthwaite
qu’une démocratie est vouée à limiter
l’expression de l’électorat.
Aucun système démocratique ne pourra garantir
qu’un président aura été élu conformément
aux vraies préférences du peuple.
À moins que… à moins que le système démocratique
en question soit aléatoire.
Dans ce cas, on peut garantir qu’aucun électeur
en particulier ne dictera l’issue de l’élection.
On peut même garantir le
fait qu’aucun électeur n’a plus d’influence
qu’un autre électeur sur l’issue de l’élection.
Ce critère, selon lequel tout électeur a
le même droit de vote, est ce que les théoriciens
des systèmes de
vote appellent l’anonymat du vote.
Et bien, le théorème de Gibbard affirme
que
le seul scrutin unanime, anonyme et sans dilemme
du
vote utile est la
dictature aléatoire, aussi connue sous le
nom de lotocracie.
Ça consiste en quoi, cette dictature aléatoire
? Et bien, chacun met un bulletin de vote
avec le nom de son candidat dans une urne
géante.
L’élu sera alors le candidat cité par
un bulletin tiré au hasard
dans l’urne !
Rien que ça ! Oui !
Le seul cas où les électeurs auront tout
intérêt à
exprimer leurs vraies préférences, c’est
ce
cas
extrême où l’élu est tiré au hasard
!
Alors, ça
peut sembler extrême.